i've seen the first oh sorry no i see a
lot of i see a lot behind you where's
the bebop where's the swordfish uh well
they don't uh hot toys and other people
have not made it yet in a new
i could give you a whole thing but okay
i'll keep going right uh so i've seen
the first six episodes yeah i'm looking
i'm looking forward to finishing uh i
did just i ran out of time um so uh
million questions i i uh um sorry i was
going to talk more about that but how
did you guys decide on 10 episodes
uh it felt like a natural fit for um
being able to tell both the bounty
stories but also the um serialized
nature of the storytelling for the
characters
uh it felt like a nice box to put
ourselves in uh and to see how much we
could really
get and it also sort of makes you live
in the choices of
where do i have to trim some stuff out
in order to
fit it this way so that's kind of how we
came to ted
well it's interesting because some of
the netflix series have been six
episodes and eight episodes and some are
ten and it's been interesting talking to
show runners about uh how they decide
what the number is because from what i
understand netflix will say here's your
budget no matter how many episodes
you're going to do so how do you want to
tell your story yeah um we started with
10 and we started talking about the
budget later i probably shouldn't say
that netflix is like don't tell
everybody else that's how it happened
but um
10 episodes felt to me appropriate in
order to get under the skin of the
characters which is really what i wanted
to do there's a lot of there is a lot of
earth to till to really understand who
these folks are where they came from
what they're being faced with what's
catching up to them and how they're
choosing to react to those moments
so it felt to me like that was the
natural progression oh no completely um
how much did netflix and and people want
to know we have a three season plan we
have a five season plan
suppose you know assuming that the show
is popular
um we have talked about those things but
none of those things were driving
conversations for sort of nailing down
this first season um in talking to them
and in this show coming to them and you
know netflix getting on board and
wanting to be on board with it um
we had a pretty solid plan of what it
was that this season was going to look
like um when walking in the door so
their sort of love and support was sort
of immediate and genuine so it made the
process really easy i know that it
obviously was terrible when john got
hurt and you know shut the production
down but everyone i've spoken to who's
involved in the making of a movie or tv
show wishes they had time in the middle
of filming to to be able to look at
everything and assess what's working and
what needs help so how did that down
time help you like make a better show
uh it was really the opportunity to go
back and look at game film you know um
yeah i got we got to go to the locker
room uh in the at the end of the first
quarter you know so in doing that it
gave us a real opportunity to look at
the storytelling to look at the scenes
to look at the sets the dialogue the way
things were cutting together uh to look
at our pacing to look at how the music
will integrate and it really provided an
incredible road map
um
for
how to come out of the locker room when
john was ready uh to get back on the
hardwood but how to come out of the
locker room and be like these are the
plays that we're gonna call and this is
how we're going to really um
hone in on on what we're chasing
did you end up reshooting anything in
the first few episodes based on that
down time because oh we need a scene
there
uh i don't
think so i think we picked up one scene
um but i think we really picked up
yeah we picked up one scene
uh and it interestingly was
uh a cutaway piece from the scene that
we went down on
um which interestingly the scene that we
went down on
um we ended up when we wrapped uh that
set we were like we shot that set in
2019 2020 and 2021.
so it was a it was sort of a bizarre
bizarre version but when we finally
wrapped that set we all gave ourselves a
nice round of applause and we're like we
made it
um the you guys have talked about easter
eggs on the series are there and i know
you don't want to give stuff away but
are there any
episodes and specific places that you
want people to maybe spend a little more
time
um it's so hard to say it's everywhere
uh it really is like every department
head from costumes to props to set deck
to painters to plasterers to
you name it were
given the directive of
plant easter eggs
uh and we all talked about them we knew
what they were going in and they would
be there and they really are
everywhere
some direct pulls from the anime some
pulls from episodes that we're borrowing
from the anime some deeper than episodes
that we're borrowing from some from
movie inspirations that tell us the
story of where the anime took its
inspirations from it really does live
everywhere but um
yeah it's just it's i could i could go
on but it's it's everywhere
one of the things um about man i have so
many more questions uh one of the things
about this is you really expanded from
the anime series uh the roles of julia
and vicious in terms of you know their
their arc and how involved they are in
the first season uh what was the
motivation of expanding their roles
a great hero needs a great enemy
and a great enemy to be realized in a
three-dimensional fashion where we truly
understand
who vicious is what vicious is why
vicious is um and the same for julia i
think that it was an incredible
opportunity um to be able to take julia
who's
more of an idea in the anime uh an
archetypal one at that than an actual
full drawn-out character and to be able
to craft a history
for julia um and tell that character's
story um but
a lot of it really hinges on uh i love a
good bad guy you know
so uh i wanted i wanted to know more
about vicious
do you think spike would actually leave
the ship if uh the ship was able to
produce delicious noodles
um
no he might if it were free he might
just stay on that ship forever
but my last thing for you because i'm
i'm out of time um the what ended up
being the really the toughest stuff to
bring to life from the anime and but the
stuff like that you loved and you're
like we need this to be in the series
but holy [ __ ] this is hard
um i think it was the overall tone
i know it's not a specific answer but it
was the tone of capturing the humor but
capturing the real and raw emotion
presenting the characters as living in a
world that
is futuristic but feels relatable
while pumping a jazzy soundtrack
and having some sort of wild pulpy slick
action
it was a
very specific needle to thread
and all of that was about truly trying
to make sure that we were capturing the
spirit of the anime
um so
part of it is like what's
pulpy fun
uh that was kind of the question like at
all times and i think that was hard to
nail down but i think we i think we i
think we found it
yeah i can't wait to finish the series
um thank you so much for your time and
um i hope it's a huge hit i hope you
guys get to make another season uh me
too fingers crossed
right exactly thank you so much so much
all right be well
you